hi this is adam from playstation grenade
and i spent the weekend shooting my way
through blizzards multiplayer weapon
fest overwatch and when I say shooting I
main basketball I've even perfected the
technique for what the fresh prince
describes us chillin out maxin relaxin
our cooling I'll shootin some b-ball
outside of the school to show your silky
skills simply choose a character that
can duck down quite low and line up your
crosshairs next to the rubber lip on the
edge of the table next up stand up and
rotate your aim to the bottom of the net
finally look back down and give that
ball a punch afterwards is your
prerogative but dance around like you
just won the NBA championship let's go
through the steps again step one duck
down and line up your crosshairs next to
the black line step 2 stand back up and
aim at the foot of the net step 3 duck
down again and fist the ball into
oblivion and finally step four celebrate
like no one is watching here's a
reminder of something not to do when
you've lined up your shot don't press
the wrong button hopefully that has been
of some use to you please pay us back by
pressing the subscribe button and make
me smile on the inside i'm adam from
playstation grenade i'll see you next
time